I'm Smith I know a Sam Smith but Sam is
a common name and so is Smith but
actually Sanford died like a couple
years ago so okay and that was not from
heaven or something as I said that would
explain the the ectoplasm or heaven all
right here we go
very simply here's the Future set if
according to Einstein and his special
theory of relativity there's no such
thing as now or indeed simultaneous
events that everything is measured
relative to something else now now he
goes into his own explanation here he
says this means the past present and
future all exists in space-time does
that mean that the future is set are we
just traveling along wow that is
philosophical and scientific at the same
time I would say there's something
getting smoked in that one as well
yeah that was a lot that with more than
that - all right so much of it was his
presumption yeah just because their time
is relative doesn't mean there isn't uh
now for you you have it now everyone has
it now so you live in you're now a
prisoner of the present locked between
the past in the future that's you so in
that world you are you have no access to
your own past nor to your own future and
holding aside any notion of predetermine
ISM that's been actually much discussed
of late where the future is set where
you do not control your next actions we
call them there's the illusion of free
will it's been argued that we don't
actually have free will but I don't want
to get into that argument this on
relativity terms okay relativity terms
you live in your own present and so I
just gotta get over hey take another
toke and you'll be fine Sam
you sleep it off only the morning cuz
I'm a joke sleep it off baby you're
gonna be just fine